[Musique]
m
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi 25 mai le
président américain rencontrera vladimir
poutine le 16 juin genève premier tête à
tête entre les deux dirigeants depuis
l'arrivée de joe biden au pouvoir de son
côté emmanuel macron estime que l'union
européenne avait besoin a besoin de
recadrer très profondément sa relation
avec la russie estimant que la politique
des sanctions était arrivé à ses limites
déclarations du président français lors
du sommet européen qui se tient en ce
moment à bruxelles de celle qui étend
ses sanctions économiques justement
contre la biélorussie annonces de berlin
qui précise que le président loukachenko
doit payer le prix fort réclamant aussi
la libération immédiate de romane
protosevich arrêté après l'atterrissage
forcé de l'avion en ligne dans lequel il
se trouvait dimanche réunion d'urgence
du conseil de sécurité de l'onu de main
sur ce dossier
anthony blinken a rencontré cet après
midi en cisjordanie le président de
l'autorité palestinienne mahmoud abbas
plus tôt dans la journée deux
secrétaires d'état américains étaient à
jérusalem où il s'est entretenu avec le
premier ministre israélien
ce dernier prévient que la réponse
d'israël sera très puissant tir le hamas
violent le cessez-le-feu
anthony hayes blinken nuit affirme qu'il
voulait éviter que le hamas bénéficient
de l'aide à la reconstruction de gaza et
que la solution à deux états reste est
la seule solution
joe weiden reçoit la famille de georgia
floyd aujourd'hui tué le 25 mai 2020
minneapolis lors de son interpellation
étouffé sous le genou du policier derek
robin le cadrage nerfs afro américain
qui est devenu un symbole de la lutte
contre le racisme
mais côté législatif le président
américain n'a pas réussi à faire voter
un texte contre les violences policières
[Musique]
vladimir poutine et joe biden se
rencontreront donc le 16 juin genève
information confirmée par le kremlin et
la maison blanche
il ne rencontre que joe biden avait dit
espérer lors de son premier déplacement
prévu en europe au mois de juin
notamment pour le sommet du g7 et de
l'otan les précisions de notre
correspondante à moscou
verhaeghe hoffman la rencontre entre le
président russe vladimir poutine et son
homologue américain joe biden aura bel
et bien lieu le 16 juin à genève comme
l'avait prédit certains médias
américains il s'agit de la première
entrevue entre les deux hommes d'état
depuis l'élection de joe biden
l'information était confirmée par le
kremlin et la maison blanche dans les
communiqués respectives
je vous propose d'écouter conformément à
l'accord conclu le président de la
fédération de russie vladimir poutine
s'entretiendra le 16 juin à genève avec
le président des états unis joseph biden
les discussions porteront sur l'état et
les perspectives de développement
ultérieur des relations russo
américaines
les sujets de stabilité stratégique
ainsi que les questions d'actualité à
l'agenda international notamment la
coopération dans la lutte contre la
pandémie de kobe de 19 et le règlement
des conflits régionaux
l'annnonce du sommet a été précédée par
une rencontre le 24 mai entre le
secrétaire du conseil de sécurité de
russie nikolaï patrouchev
avec le conseiller à la sécurité
nationale du président américain jake
sullivan le 19 mai encore les chefs de
la diplomatie des deux pays antony
blinken et sergueï lavrov s'étaient
rencontrés en islande pour la première
fois depuis les changements du
gouvernement aux états unis le ministre
russe des affaires étrangères sergueï
lavrov avait déclaré à cette occasion
que les deux nations comprenait la
nécessité de mettre fin au climat
malsain qui s'était formé dans les
relations ces dernières années côté
américain tony blinken a dit qu'il était
d'avis que si les leaders de la russie
et des états unis peuvent travailler
ensemble
le monde entier peut être un endroit
plus sûr notant cependant des approches
très différentes en ce qui concerne
l'analyse de la situation sur la scène
internationale la biélorussie qui sera
donc sans doute au menu des discussions
entre joe biden et vadim
poutine aguila merkel a annoncé
aujourd'hui que les 27 allaient étendre
les sanctions économiques contre minsk
et ajoute de nouveaux individus à
réalisation sur la liste noire
réactions après l'interception dimanche
d'un avion ligne qui transportait un ex
collaborateur d'un média d'opposition
biélorusse
les dirigeants de l'union européenne qui
ont aussi fermé leur espace aérien à
minsk où bruxelles demande la libération
immédiate de romana brotas zeevi tx est
détaillé avec hélène masculine le
président biélorusse doit payer le prix
fort pour un acte infâme ces mots du
chef de la diplomatie allemande
traduisent le ton de bruxelles à l'égard
de minsk et d'alexandre loukachenko lors
d'un sommet spécial ce lundi les 27 se
sont accordés comme rarement
en moins de deux heures la décision
était prise
la biélorussie doit être sanctionné on
ne peut plus faire confiance à la sûreté
et à la sécurité des vols passant par
l'espace aérien de la biélorussie et le
conseil adoptera des mesures pour
interdire le survol de l'espace aérien
de l'union européenne ait refusé l'accès
aux aéroports aux aéroports de l'union
européenne aux avions biélorusse
ces mesures drastiques vise directement
le président biélorusse accusé par lieu
d'avoir détourné un avion commercial
européen dans le seul but d'arrêter ran
opposant romane protasiewicz dont elle
réclame la libération
depuis ce mardi un certain nombre de
compagnies aérienne austrian airlines
air france finnair ou singapore airlines
ont annoncé que leurs vols éviterait dès
ce mardi l'espace aérien biélorusse seul
allié de minsk moscou de son côté
fustige la réaction européenne
il faut comprendre qu'en fin de compte
ce sont les passagers des avions qui
paieront pour ses recommandations et qui
passeront 30 minutes ou une heure de
plus en l'air
tout cela coûte de l'argent ça se
calcule et on ne peut donc qu exprimer
des regrets
de son côté l'otan exigent d'urgence la
mise en place d'une enquête
internationale pour déterminer ce qui
s'est passé une requête à laquelle minsk
se dit parfaitement ouvertes
nous demandons à l'organisation de
l'aviation civile internationale à
l'association du transport aérien
international à l'âge osseux européenne
de la sécurité aérienne des
représentants des administrations de
l'aviation concernés de participer à une
enquête impartiale sur l'événement
interdiction de séjour gel des avoirs et
embargo ces sanctions sont loin d'être
nouvelle les premières mesures
restrictives imposées à la biélorussie
remonte à 2004 et jusqu'à présent elles
n'ont jamais intimider alexandre
loukachenko en attendant de voir les
effets de ces nouvelles mesures
l'opposition biélorusse s'invite au g7
qui se tiendra du 11 au 13 juin au
royaume uni une demande à laquelle le
président français emmanuel macron s'est
dit favorable dans le même temps le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu a annoncé
la tenue d'une réunion d'urgence ce
mercredi et en marge du sommet de
l'union européenne emmanuel macron s'est
exprimé sur ce dossier biélorusse sursis
que sur les relations entre les
vingt-sept et la russie écoutez je pense
qu'à très court terme il n'y avait pas
de réponse plus efficace face à ce qui
s'est passé d' inacceptables en
biélorussie et donc l'enquète de l'ouest
et y déclencher je pense que les mesures
de restriction des vols particulier de
survol de l'espace européen sont
extrêmement mordantes sur le système
bello russe et puis enfin des sanctions
additionnelles
est ce que cela sera suffisant je ne
sais absolument pas vous le dire
aujourd'hui
je pense que cela aura plus d'impact que
ce qu'on avait pris jusque là parce que
c'est plus dur et le caractère
inacceptable de ce qui s'est passé
dimanche matin le justifie maintenant
comme vous je pense que nous sommes à un
moment de vérité dans notre relation
avec la russie qui doit nous conduire à
repenser les termes de l'attention qu'on
décide d'installer
donc ce n'est à mes yeux qu'une étape et
pour en parler nous sommes avec karine
avait checcolo fco professeur invité à
l'université d'état de moscou bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous on vient
d'entendre dans ses propos d' emmanuel
macron l'europe qui semble mettre
biélorussie et russie véritablement dans
le même panier il est vrai que le
kremlin apporté de facto son soutien à
alexandre loukachenko pour autant
peut-on faire un lien aussi direct dans
ce dossier entre minsk et moscou
bonsoir c'était vie c'est effectivement
quand même un glissement politique qui
est assez surprenant
à moins de ne pas considérer que la
vieille russie soit un pays souverain
distingue de la russie qu'elle est un
pays souverain
le fait que ces deux pays et hulene
contestataires par rapport à la
domination atlantis ne veut pas dire que
ce soit un seul et même pays mais cela
s'explique aussi autrement c'est que la
ligne injustement atlantis est
différente face à la biélorussie que 1
et face à la russie par rapport à la
biélorussie ils sont une position
actuellement compliquée puisqu'ils n'ont
pas besoin de forcer trop ils ne veulent
pas réellement une rupture parce qu'ils
ont besoin de faire plier le pays et
pour qu'à prier le pays il faut pouvoir
compter le travail et l'intérieur or à
force de multiplier les sanctions il
s'éloigne de la bélarussie il envoie la
biélorussie vers la russie ce qui en
fait ne correspond pas à l'intérêt
atlantis
or pourquoi la russie apparaît tout à
coup dans ce jeu là parce qu'il faut
bien tapé pour montrer sa force et
l'intérêt de taper sur la russie en fait
aussi puisque la russie elle à la
différence de la ville de russie ne peut
évidemment pas être intégrée elle ne
peut être que des truites
donc cela explique en fait ce glissement
cette espèce d'amalgamé malsain qui est
continuellement fait lorsqu'il s'agit de
cet événement de dimanche ont bien
réussi alors vladimir poutine va
recevoir
loukachenko en fin de semaine quelle va
être l'attitude du président russe
vis-à-vis du président biélorusse selon
vous la russie et la biélorussie ont de
nombreux domaines de coopération qui la
développe indépendamment de l'âge mon
terreau nationale agenda international
la réaction absolument hystérique de la
communauté internationale actuelle va
conduire le cash and co a cherché à se
rapprocher la russie alors que rappelons
qu'il a toujours une position quelque
peu ambiguë entre l'occident d'un côté
la russie de l'autre il joue toujours un
peu sur les deux chaises mais il est
vrai que la radicalisation de l'occident
après les dernières élections
présidentielles le soutien ouvert à
apporter à l'opposition qui fomentent
quand même un coup d'état
retournement de situation depuis les
élections conduit en fait et le cash and
co à se rapprocher de poutine qui lui
est prêt évidemment à intensifier les
relations avec la blé logo ci puisque
cela correspond à l'intérêt des deux
pays
alors emmanuel macron évoqué le possible
durcissement des sanctions dans ce
dossier biélorusse mais estime dans le
même temps que la politique des
sanctions était arrivé à ses limites
envers la russie comme d'ailleurs envers
la biélorussie à quelle stratégie
s'attendre désormais le problème
justement de l'union européenne puisque
les pme les pays membres de l'union
européenne sont complètement dépendants
en fait de cette institution et qu'elle
n'a strictement aucune stratégie
et c'est bien le problème parce que si
elle défendrait les intérêts de l'europe
la culture européenne du continent
européen
elle ça fait des années qu'elle ne
mènerait pas cette politique agressive
de sanctions contre la russie qui est
une politique extrêmement destructrice
lorsque l'on entend se massent dire que
le cash and co est une espèce de monstre
qui prend sa population en otage
on se demande en fait qui est en train
actuellement de discuter de sanctions
économiques donc qu'ils vont avoir un
impact sur la population sur le niveau
social de viande vélo et cie c'est
d'aller
bien ce qui est attendu et c'est bien ce
qu'a exprimé mâcon
il attend que cela devient beaucoup plus
difficile pour la vie au quotidien des
gaules russe et que dans ce chantage
finalement il lâche le cas chaque gauche
je trouve quand même au minimum cette
position absolument amoral et
profondément une alors c'est dans ce
contexte que la maison blanche annonce
officiellement sa rencontre avec
vladimir poutine le 16 juin raconte
confirmée par le kremlin
même si c'était attendu cette annonce
est elle pour autant à un hasard du
calendrier
non ce n'est pas un hasard du calendrier
puisque c'est le moment lors duquel le
président américain fait sa tournée on
pourrait dire presque souveraine en
europe et à l'occasion de cette tournée
justement il va accorder quelques temps
au président russe pour discuter comme
l'a déclaré que ça qui la porte parole
de la maison blanche en sept rencontres
correspond tout à fait à la défense des
intérêts des américains il est à
souhaiter qu'elles correspondent
également à la défense des intérêts de
la russie puisque les positions de des
états unis et de la russie sont
diamétralement opposées et leurs
intérêts sont difficilement compatibles
puisque les états unique dans leur
retour comme centre du monde global ont
besoin réellement d'occuper
idéologiquement et donc politiquement
tout le territoire et la russie pour
exister en tant que pays comme l est
comme russie avec sa culture ses
traditions ses intérêts proches
justement a besoin de marquer sa
différence
il va être quelque peu difficile de
trouver un accord merci beaucoup karine
avait checcolo fco professeur invité à
l'université d'état de moscou d'avoir
été avec nous
le secrétaire d'état américain anthony
blinken s'est rendu à ramallah
aujourd'hui où il a rencontré le chef de
l'autorité palestinienne mahmoud abbas
au quatrième jour de la trêve au proche
orient le chef de la diplomatie
américaine anthony blinken s'est
entretenu avec les différents chefs
d'état israélien et palestinien
l'occasion d'apporter son soutien aux
deux parties avant d'annoncer des
mesures d' aide au peuple palestinien
dont notamment un apport de 75 millions
de dollars pour la reconstruction de
gaza écouter comme je l'aï dit au
premier ministre netanyahu et au
président abbas les états unis veulent
avancer sur la réouverture du consulat à
jérusalem
c'est une façon importante pour notre
pays de s'engager et d'apporter son
soutien au peuple palestinien
j'ai informé le président abbas et avant
cela le premier ministre netanyahu que
les états unis vont informer le congrès
de notre intention de fournir 75
millions de dollars dette supplémentaire
au développement et à l'économie des
palestiniens en 2020 peur et on trouve
sur place notre correspondant à ramallah
mohamed hamayel bonsoir waben à bayel
merci d'être avec nous ces annonces du
chef de la diplomatie américaine avec
notamment ces êtres comment elles ont
été accueillies dans les territoires
voulez-vous dire en général la visite
anthony blinken
les annonces donc d' anthony blinken
notamment ces aides envers les
territoires comment ont-elles été
accueilli ces annonces de anthony
blinken
là où vous êtes à ramallah dans les
territoires la déclaration dette a été
bien accueillie par l'autorité
palestinienne ne sait pas vraiment
quelle a été la réaction sur le terrain
mais officiellement à ramallah pour
l'autorité palestinienne à cette annonce
de 75 millions de dollars dette
économique a été a accueilli avec
plaisir cela s'ajoute aux 5 5 millions
de dollars des deux d'urgente ce pour
reconstruire à la bande de gaza et il
verra également annoncé par un tony
blair de 32 millions de dollars pour l
air de je vais à pour les palestiniens
les réfugiés palestiniens
tous ces progrès ont été accueillis bien
accueillis par l'autorité palestinienne
dans les rues cependant n'y avait pas
autant d'excitation car il s'agit cela
est dans la continuité des politiques de
à l'administration avant donne à 30 sur
le terrain la situation est très
instable
un palestinien a été tué par des forces
israéliennes avant la visite et anthony
pleinement le génome a été confondu avec
son oncle car il était dans sa voiture
donc il y avait beaucoup de scepticisme
vis-à-vis t cette visite alors anthony
blinken qui a quand même annoncé la
volonté des états unis 1 d'avancé sur le
processus de réouverture du consulat à
jérusalem
il a également reparler de la solution
deux états qui clairement serait la
seule solution aujourd'hui dans ce
processus étant même une rupture très
claire par rapport à son prédécesseur le
constater beaucoup de palestiniens de
demander un consulat il propose des
services nécessaires pour les
palestiniens et ils sont bien accueillir
cette étape vers la reconstruction des
relations avec les états unis tout en
plus important pour certains dans une
ère post it runs
car pendant l'ère trump beaucoup de
palestiniens n'ont pas pu avoir accès
aux services du consulat après sa
fermeture à jérusalem pour beaucoup de
personnes c'est un progrès vers une
amélioration des relations entre
palestine et états unis pour beaucoup de
palestiniens cela facilite les relations
avec l'ambassade américaine qui a été
ouverte durant la présidence de donald
trump à jérusalem donc cela atténue se
camoufler les thaïs cependant j'ai
encore beaucoup de rancoeur concernant
la situation à gen re aiment ce qui
arrive en ce moment
à jérusalem ce qui a lancé cette
escalade d'il ya quelques semaines merci
moi mais de la mayenne journalistes à
ramallah merci d'avoir été avec nous
alors quelle place et quelle influence
surtout pour l'amérique de joe biden
dans ce conflit quel rôle ont joué les
américains dans ce cessez le feu c'est
l'objet de notre décryptage ce soir est
avec nous pour en parler
gideon un coude ce journaliste israélien
correspondant à paris à ses côtés
françois costantini et géopolitologue
bonsoir messieurs merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france donc visite un
petit peu compliqué tout de même pour
anthony blinken car les états unis n'ont
pour l'instant pas brillé dans ce
dossier on le rappelle c'est les gîtes
aussi la jordanie qui ont oeuvré à la
mise en place du cessez-le-feu pour les
américains ont bloqué les résolutions à
l'onu
est ce que on peut dire que c'est la
première erreur de l'administration
baydan à l'international françois
constantini bonsoir
à mon avis c'est pas tant une erreur que
des tâtonnements multiples
l'administration by john arrive après
l'administration trump qui avaient des
positions nettes rangés par exemple
l'accord d'abraham qui est extrêmement
important on n'a pas entendu
l'administration blaye buydens se
prononcer sur l'accord à bas à brax
alors je sais que c'est un peu excentré
par rapport à la région mais le maroc
par exemple aujourd'hui n'a toujours pas
eu de deux réponses ou moins de
confirmation par l'administration
américaine
voilà une administration américaine qui
tâtonnaient qui en est aujourd'hui à
jouer à la marge sur des z 75 millions $
c'est pas énorme en terme de
reconstruction mais également qui se
questionnent sur savoir quelle va être
la destination est dans les faits si
cette manne aussi modique soit elle va
pouvoir échapper au hamas et on parle de
solution à deux états mais solution de
l'aseta encore faudrait-il qu'ils les
reconstitutions de la décision
palestinienne ce qui est très improbable
aujourd'hui avec le report des élections
et puis là la scission qui lie avec la
masse qui tient à la bande de gaza et le
fatah qui est qui est le tien
la cij la cisjordanie et on a une
administration en fait légalement tenu
par un certain nombre de considérations
internes puisque le spectre qui a un job
haydn au pouvoir il faut pas oublier il
y a également des gens qui sont plutôt
favorables à israël traditionnement mais
il ya également dans ce qu'on appelle
minorité est également dans ce qu'on
appelle un certain nombre de courants
très à gauche et des gens des leaders
d'opinion qui sont plutôt défavorable à
israël
et c'est peut-être en effet quelque
chose de nouveau dans la halle dans une
même pot à laquelle une administration
démocrate va devoir faire face et avec
laquelle va devoir d'ailleurs prendront
vraisemblablement vidéo coûte ce même
diagnostic comment vous vous jugez le
rôle des états unis dans cette trêve du
tâtonnement comme nous le dit françois
constantini et du tâtonnement volontaire
ou tout simplement de stratégie ou de
conviction sur sur le sujet écoutez
tâtonnements et peut-être c'est un début
de cette administration un première
grande d'une première dans l'implication
d'un risque on attendait peut-être mais
j'étais assez attendu et qui est venu
très tôt mais je pense quand même que le
président wade qui était considéré un
épais comme un billet
voilà messieurs est déjà dépassé
peut-être et
à quand même jouait son hôte à mal son
rôle pendant la crise l effet que d'une
part c'est lui qui a décidé quand c'est
fait s'est défait aura lieu et d'autre
part il a laissé aux historiens
et quand même de réagir à ces et
pourtant qu'ils ont voulu et à cette
attaque a fait attaquer du famas donc
plutôt une image positive et du
président biden en israël il était
soupçonné de tous les maux dès le début
et maintenant et les états unis ont
quand même un certaine stature et dans
des essais timides dans la résolution de
cette crise l effet que l europe pour la
france
essayez par exemple de promouvoir une
une pollution et de sécurité
ce qui n'a pas marché et donc les états
unis on trouvait je pense au début de
cette crise qu'il entendait jouer un
rôle central et ils ont prouvé leur
influence et maintenant ce qui concerne
ce qui va donner l'aide qu'elle sert à
laver
c'est une autre chose est naturellement
et naturellement il faudra compter avec
les faits que les élections n'ont pas eu
lieu
est-ce que l'autorité palestinien
continuera à être l'interlocuteur est
désisté un lien si si si si les
négociations reprennent et c'est une
politique des petits pas et dans
laquelle et les états unis essaye de
ménager les l'est des côtes est et par
exemple elle s'est acquittée et des ré
ouvrir et les consulats
nous avons entendu monsieur blinken le
retrouverez les consulats et à jérusalem
est un conte pense quand même la
décision de laisser l'ambassade des
états unis à jérusalem
les élus étaient transférés par les
présidents tombent donc jusqu'à
maintenant je ne pense pas que
l'administration américaine ait trouvé
trop trop et trop d'amateurisme si vous
voulez d'hésitation françois constantini
en tout cas c'est une vraie rupture
effectivement avec l'air trump à la
volonté d'avancer sur ce processus de
réouverture du consulat à l'aide de 75
millions d'euros et surtout cette
solution en deux étapes qui semble comme
le rappelle anthony blinken pour lui est
la seule solution il ya une vraie
rupture est ce que ça serait de nature
selon vous à faire avancer ce processus
de paix tout de même oui alors il est
vrai qu'en effet il ya une rupture il
faut pas oublier que le dernier plan
d'administration trump si en effet le
les accords abraham est un succès le
clan cuche meneur puisque c'était manqué
côté par le propre jambe de donald trump
jared kushner sur la cisjordanie et gaza
ne tenait pas en effet il était
totalement irréaliste et il était en
tout cas en l'état il ne pouvait pas
être acceptable par par les palestiniens
puisque il y avait annexion la veille du
jourdain il y avait un ex y ont en effet
dû de certaines parties périphériques de
la cisjordanie
et puis on avait de façon fantaisiste
des donnes qui était donné au sud
d'israël
on va faire des technopoles je sais quoi
donc c'est cet accord n'était pas
acceptable en l'état s'il y a en effet
solution à deux états qui à mon sens
c'est la seule solution viable
elle doit s'appuyer sur la résolution
242 en sachant avec néanmoins être deux
de limites c'est que 1 il doit avoir des
arrangements de sécurité notamment pour
israël sur sur ce que j'appelle non pas
le contenu mais le contenant les et les
frontières extérieures et puis ensuite d
accord définitif entre israël entre
israéliens et palestiniens sur la
question de la capitale sur la sur les
les transferts entre cisjordanie et gaza
on en est loin mais il est vrai que
visiblement l'administration byden
revient difficilement atteindre par
tâtonnement monsieur a évoqué les petits
pas c'est un mot ces lettres dans la
région puisque c'était la doctrine
kissinger la doctrine des petits pas
justement on est toujours moment donc
ces petits pas mais il est vrai que
l'administration baydan y revient
lancement reste à savoir si c'est sur
vous alors aaron david miller ancien
diplomate américain lui a son avis sur
la question je vous propose de l'écouter
un ce chercheur émérite à la fondation
carnegie pour la paix internationale
regardez ce qu'ils en pensent joe biden
fait le choix de la prudence en
politique étrangère en se concentrant
uniquement sur les dossiers qui ont des
conséquences pour les américains comme
la chine et le climat au moyen orient
un seul sujet entre dans cette catégorie
le nucléaire iranien
gideon coutts vous êtes d'accord avec ce
diagnostic c'est une forme de visites
intéressés c'est pour ça que les
américains se déplace aujourd'hui la
menace iranienne
via le hamas oui la menace iranienne
existait pas uniquement via le hamas il
ya plusieurs autres en danger de
confrontation de plus en plus directes
avec israël et aller retour attendu des
américains dans l'accord nucléaire qu'on
aimait ne sais pas ce qu'il va ce qu'il
va donner bien sûr que la menace est
gagnant est prise au sérieux
il faut l'espérer et aux états unis mais
le problème est aussi comment un retour
éventuel et à cet accord sera pris en
israël et je voudrais insister sur la
relation où les relations de confiance
entre les américains et israël et
c'était un grand test
et pour pour pour le président mbaye de
neige je répète ce que je dis je pense
que le début n'est pas si nouvelle n'est
pas si mauvais c'est cette confiance va
très important si on voudrait vraiment
est arrivé
certains n'ont hélas cette solution des
deux états avec modification etc
on sait pas encore et suite au plan
américain qui était plutôt destiné pour
gagner du temps réaliste et en ce qui
concerne et les accords d'abraham le
faut on se voit moins de soucis et pour
l'instant ces accords la marche très
très bien très bien on a vu les
réactions et pendant et c'était petit
gué avec les famas et de la part des
pays qui participent et recel prémices
marocain que lui est un islamiste et
envoyé une lettre de félicitations et
ont ramassé sinon tous les autres ont
tenu bon moi j'ai eu l'occasion et de
rencontrer à paris le premier ministre
sous d'années et qui étaient ici à la
conférence et d'aquio soudan appui à la
concurrence depuis économique de
l'afrique et il m'a dit très clairement
il m'a dit très clairement et que est là
normalisation avec israël va continuer
et malgré tout et qu'est ce qui se passe
entre historiens palestiniens avec la
suite de cette normalisation qui est n 1
retour du soudan au sein de la famille
internationale
je pense que pour l'instant les accords
de tiers et il faut voir encore la suite
qui n'est pas du tout sûr surtout en ce
qui concerne aussi la reine
palestinienne mahmoud abbas qui l'ont à
la fin de son parcours il faut voir donc
ce qui peut se passer au sein de
l'autorité palestinienne
françois constantini pour pour résumer
ce débat ce décryptage plutôt quel poids
selon vous hante encore les états unis
au proche orient on a vu récemment
qu'ils n'ont pas pu empêcher notamment
l'armée israélienne de détruire un
immeuble dans lequel cg la perle agences
de presse américaines ce cas une vraie
influence encore alors une nuance quand
même un sens sans prendre de partir
entre israël et bali sien c'est que les
israéliens ou pas m'appeler une
demi-heure avant les occupants de
l'immeuble en leur disant qu'ils
allaient bombarder l'immeuble et tout le
monde a été évacué
la l'immeuble a été a été détruit il ya
eu zéro mort alors qu'on soit contre ou
pour israélien israël il faut quand même
le signaler c'est que les israéliens et
les pressions des dispositions c'est
comme ça c'est quand encore très rare
aujourd'hui l'endroit de la guerre et
des conflits pour pour ce qui est en
effet du poids des etats-unis de pons
des faits qu'il ya comme vous l'avez
signalé il ya un gros point qui est la
question du nucléaire iranien avec le
fameux le pea cg de plan d'action commun
général le chip lead way en anglo saxons
roues à savoir est ce qu'aujourd'hui les
états unis vont revenir à mon avis n'ont
pas pris décision ils sont en train
d'examiner la situation
notamment la question de
l'enrichissement de l'uranium puisque
normalement l'accord de genève
orthez v8 à 3,67 pour son enrichissement
certaines sources à vérifier font état
de 18 à 20% aujourd'hui degré
d'enrichissement de la part des iraniens
ce qui serait en contravention avec
l'accord mais il est vrai que l'accord
avec le retrait des états unis est
pratiquement plusieurs c'est un accord
qui est qu'elle est qu'elle est requis
entre donc en effet les états sur
influence sur un avion il ya la question
également des relations avec l'arabie
saoudite en effet envoie une arabie
saoudite aujourd'hui qui acquit à qui
craint un retour des états unis que jc
perreault et qui on prend des relations
tout azimut avec la rookie avec la chine
avait avec avec un capteur avec un peu
tout le monde puisque il faut pas
oublier que la cour abraham a été rendue
possible avec l'accord tacite notamment
de l'arabie saoudite n'ont ni les
émirats ni bahreïn a fortiori n'aurait
signé les alors c'est avec les ats-unis
insisté sur l'iran sur l'arabie saoudite
et en espérant que le dossier iranien
une fois une fois déverrouiller évitera
en quelque sorte qui est ce qu on
appelle ces ses propres influences que
sont à la fois leur hamas us voilà comme
été actionnée à chaque fois clients à
venir on a des problèmes c'est pas un
hasard non plus peut-être partie le
hamas à l'actionnement cette occasion et
puis on a peu parlé mais le laisse bola
également avait expliqué quelques
roquettes mais de façon limitée
cette fois ci sur le sur le nord
d'israël donc en effet l'eau d'initier
ses principales de ce lien
pourquoi parce qu'il tient à l'équilibré
stratégique de la région
en effet c'est aujourd'hui le dossier
diplomatique et stratégique essentiel
aux cochons
merci à tous les deux françois
constantini gideon coûte d'avoir été
avec nous pour ce décryptage sur le rôle
des etats-unis au proche-orient
et puis nous rester avec nous partirons
dans quelques instants aux états unis
non après la mort de john floyd ce mardi
et joe biden reçoit sa famille sa
réforme de la police ont misé avant le
premier anniversaire de la mort de
l'afro américain a retardé
elle nous en parlerons dans notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur en direct de
stamford dans le connecticut
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce sont les trafics de drogue d'une
certaine façon qui sont peut-être les
meilleurs adeptes de la mondialisation
c'est à dire que ils ont inventé les
routes de la drogue bien avant que les
entreprises ne découvrent les bienfaits
de la mondialisation on ne visualise pas
à quel point ça peut être compliqué de
se retrouver avec dans son garage
montagnes de billets de banque comme ça
il faut en faire quelque chose l'argent
sale devient très rapidement et très
facilement en gris et puis blanc il
suffit de passer par quelques sociétés
écrans
mais à côté de ça vous avez tout un
réseau de banques qui sont beaucoup plus
ouverte au cash à l'époque de la crise
de 2008 vous dit même que les banques
qui ont été beaucoup moins regardante
sur la provenance de cet argent qui
arrivaient pour renflouer les caisses ça
a été même dire nations unies on a
constaté que plusieurs dizaines de
milliards issus du trafic de stupéfiants
ont été absorbés par un certain nombre
de banques aux états unis qui d'ailleurs
ont été poursuivis en justice et ont
payé des amendes en conséquence
[Musique]
après six mois de fermeture commerce non
essentiels terrasse ou encore cinéma ont
rouvert leurs portes le 19 mai lors
forcément le redémarrage peut parfois
être laborieux déjà on angoisse beaucoup
d'endroits autres les équipes de
reprendre un rythme avec en plus des
restrictions qui sont délicates pour
travailler correctement les projections
de croissance etc c'est exceptionnel
on a eu je doute qu'elles soient
réalisées aussi facilement que ça il va
falloir quand même avoir une vision de
relance il vient d'accompagner un peu
plus longue
on navigue presque un petit peu a vu
quand les aides vont s'arrêter
il est assez probable que ça fasse
beaucoup de dégâts parce qu'on a à voir
et le deuxième tour fatal derrière et un
autre confinement septembre tobre serait
dramatique pour la profession et
moralement terrible où on nous vend du
rêve et malheureusement ça se transforme
vite en cauchemar
le ms a exhorté certains pays d'afrique
à ne pas détruire les vaccins anti covit
péri mais il faut craindre une
vaccination low cost en afrique lors une
vaccination reste une vaccination savez
la vaccination ce n'est pas elle n'a pas
commencé avec la guitare
le problème ça reste quand même
l'approvisionnement est ce que c'est la
faute des pays les plus riches qui
accapare justement les productions de
l'accent
où est le mécanisme de la vaccination
vous savez ça a soulevé beaucoup
d'enjeux sur la question de la
solidarité si on peut en faire plus en
terme de solidarité de partage de ces
bacs cela c'est quelque chose
d'absolument important on sait que le
nigeria affirme qu'il élabore son propre
vaccin contre le coc vie de 19 pour en
finir avec justement la dépendance
vis-à-vis des laboratoires étrangers
que ce soit le sénégal le nigeria
l'afrique du sud beaucoup de pays ont
cette admission l'avoir amené l'agenda
de la santé publique au top des
priorités c'est quelque chose que nous
saluons énormément au niveau de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
[Musique]
la repentance est un sentiment aux
conséquences extrêmement graves pour
l'avenir
cette pratique obsessionnel s'imposant
l'esprit de nos dirigeants comme la
condition incontournable d'une
gouvernance responsable moderne plutôt
que de se repentir
on ferait mieux de faire référence à un
passé dont on peut être fier
nous trouvons un autre exemple des
limites de cette transparence dans
l'utilisation de la raison d'état pour
cacher la vérité sous la pression
médiatique et la raison d'état on
pratique une sélection du bien et du mal
à géométrie variable
il faut sauver la liberté d'expression
qui est prise en otage dans une
inversion entre le juste et le client
[Musique]
soyez les bienvenus en direct sur arte
france si vous nous rejoignez la famille
de giorgio floyd à washington ce mardi
un an jour pour jour après la mort du
quadragénaire afro-américains la famille
qui a rencontré la présidente de la
chambre nancy pelosi et la représentante
démocrate karen bass principales
négociatrices tu de la chambre sur le
projet de loi sur les services de police
une rencontre dans le but d'inciter de
congrès à agir puisque si le décès de
georges frêche a déclenché des appels à
une réforme de la police une réponse
législative n'a toujours pas été donné
les négociateurs du congrès reste
néanmoins optimiste en vue d'un projet
de loi peut être même d'un accord dès
cette semaine et ce décès s'était donc
qu'il y a un an jour pour jour on disait
un événement à l'origine d'un mouvement
d'ampleur contre le racisme le drame
dépasse alors les frontières américaines
notamment avec un blake lively madère
retour sur les faits le 25 mai 2000
ventes georges floyd un afro américain
de 46 ans meurt par asphyxie à
minneapolis
l'homme a été victime d'une technique
d'immobilisation policière des règles
chauvine le policier maintien
l'interpeller au sol en appuyant avec
son genou sur sa nuque
pendant près de 9 minutes dès le
lendemain des manifestations
s'organisent au cri de black lips matin
malgré le limogeage des quatre policiers
impliqués
elle gagne plusieurs villes américaines
à l'instar de new york los angeles ou
encore la capitale washington
face à ces contestations donald trump
alors président des états unis promet de
stopper la violence collective
dénonce les agissements de gauchistes
radicaux et menace de déployer l'armée
la mort de georges floyd provoque un
mouvement mondial
il devient le symbole de la lutte contre
les violences policières et le racisme
systémique le mouvement black like the
matters prend une ampleur internationale
le calcio
après trois semaines d'un procès
hors-norme des règles ovine est reconnu
coupable le 20 avril 2021 du meurtre de
george floyd l'ex-policier encourt douze
ans et demi de prison sa peine sera
prononcée le 25 juin prochain des
conditions aggravante demandé par le
procureur pourrait alourdir sa sentence
[Musique]
la sphère just fly da bouleversé la
politique américaine en mars dernier la
chambre des représentants à majorité
démocrate a adopté la loi de georges
floyd qui vise à réformer la police
le texte prévoit l'interdiction des
prises d'étranglement de rendre
obligatoire la collecte de données sur
les interventions de la police ou encore
de financer des programmes de police de
proximité
toutefois le projet n'a pas encore été
adopté par le sénat
l'année dernière déjà un projet
similaire avait été rejetée par le sénat
à majorité républicaine
ce schéma pourrait se reproduire cette
année les républicains affirment que ces
mesures pourraient empêcher la police de
faire son travail efficacement ce 25 mai
joe biden a décidé d'accueillir la
famille de georges floyd à la maison
blanche
un an jour pour jour après la mort de
leurs proches
tout un symbole joe biden recevra dans
la journée la famille de georges floyd
donc le président américain qui espérait
faire voter un texte contre les
violences policières guillemin rossi
pour le symbole c'est raté
les discussions sur le texte traînant en
longueur la loi sur la réforme de la
police aux états unis n'aura pas été
adoptée avant le premier anniversaire de
la mort de georges floyd il faut dire
que concilier les points de vue sur ce
texte n'a rien de facile
les débats se concentrent notamment sur
la qualif hyde immunity ou immunité
qualifié en france est un principe
juridique qu'ils accordent aux forces de
l'ordre aux etats unis une immunité très
large même en cas de bavure
la loi prévoit d'amender
disposition alors que les républicains
et sont opposés ceci étant dit cette loi
concerne uniquement la police fédérale
américaine
or aux états unis il y a aussi les
polices d'état de comté ou les polices
municipales en tout on compte environ
18000 services de forces de l'ordre à
travers le pays
chacun avec ses propres règles et après
la mort de georges claude de nombreuses
initiatives locales ont émergé pour
tenter de les réformer le 12 juin 2020
l'état de new york à par exemple
prohiber les techniques d'étranglement
élevé la confidentialité des dossiers
disciplinaires des agents de police
cette loi a d'ailleurs pris le nom
d'eric garner à cet autre afro américain
décédé le 17 juillet 2014 à new york
dans des circonstances similaires à la
mort de georgetown au kentucky
le gouverneur de l'état a quant à lui
signé début avril un projet de loi pour
limiter les notes wade que l'on pourrait
traduire par descente sans sommation
c'est à dire lorsque les forces de
l'ordre pénètre dans une habitation sans
aucune notification préalable
sans sonner ils frappèrent à la porte un
type d'intervention qui a causé la mort
de bréau nat taylor l'an dernier dans la
nuit du 12 au 13 mars 2020 les policiers
ont enfoncé la porte de son appartement
sans avertissement qui n'y soit le coeur
le compagnon de bréau n'a croyant à un
cambriolage a ouvert le feu sur les
agents ces derniers ont riposté certains
en tirant des dizaines de balles aveugle
et ont abattu bréau nattés lors de six
balles à l'abdomen
une étude sur les 100 plus grands
services de police des villes
américaines révèle que près des trois
quarts d'entre eux interdisent
dorénavant ou limitent fortement
l'emploi des techniques d'étranglement
soit 43 de plus en une année ils sont
également 81 services de police a exigé
que leurs agents avertissent verbalement
avant de tirer et 20 d'entre eux
interdisent tout tire sur des véhicules
en mouvement
en l'absence de menace mortelle tout
cela devrait se traduire par moins de
violence de la part des forces de
l'ordre aux états unis reste tout de
même d'importants problèmes de fond
comme la circulation des armes à feu
dans le pays selon le washington post
environ 1000 personnes sont abattues
tous les ans par la police américaine
est déjà plus de 350 rien que depuis le
début de l'année statistiquement les
noirs ont plus de deux fois plus de
risques d'être tué par la police que les
blancs aux états unis et ils pourront
parler nous sommes en direct depuis
standford avec allen
or avocat c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir les normes
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france le dernier chiffre que l'on vient
d'entendre et marquant les personnes
noires américaines auraient deux fois et
demi plus de risques d'être tué par la
police que les personnes de couleur
blanche comment ce déséquilibre est il
encore possible au 21ème siècle aux
états unis des problèmes que nous
essayons tout traité en ce moment
pourquoi cela existe aux états unis ou
dans d'autres régions mais tu demandes
ce mouvement a lancé une conversation
mondiale sur les vies étaient personnes
noires alors joe biden a souhaité une
réforme avant le premier anniversaire de
la mort de georges de floride il
travaillant sur ce que vous nous dites
c'est la mission du moment c'est raté
manifestement il reçoit en tout cas la
famille de la victime à la maison
blanche est ce que c'est suffisant il
aurait mieux fallu un bon projet loi
n'est ce pas ne suis pas le président le
président l'administration actuelle ont
fait ce qu'ils ont pu
face au congrès de loi au sénat car il y
a été parfaite entre les démocrates et
les républicains au sénat et les
républicains le contrôle à la valeur
d'une réforme
l'importance pour les autorités
américaines donc c'est le congrès qui
est responsable
le président a fait tout ce qui était et
continue à oeuvrer pour changer la donne
notamment par exemple cette immigration
corriger certaines décisions notamment
par exemple en matière de formation des
policiers
certaines personnes sont tendances et
les problèmes ne mérite pas d'être
policier était qualifié par exemple est
un problème et interdire l ess clé
d'étranglement c'est également très
important qu'est ce que reprochent les
membres du congrès à ce texte pour qu
est ce qui pose problème pourquoi l'on
qu'il refusait une grande partie cela
concerne la culture et de qualifier à
l'assurance c'est vrai pour les avocats
ou et pour les médecins qui sont
responsables s'ils y mène à la mort de
quelqu'un donc à quoi les policiers ne
sont ils pas sujet aux mêmes jeux
nécessité cela à l'histoire de la police
aux états unis qui s'est développée à
partir des patrons je pense que beaucoup
d'autres pays comme la france une
discussion entre faire comprendre aux
gens quel que soit leur origine que tout
le monde est égal clairement est ce que
cette réforme de la police peut-elle
penser sans une réforme du port d'armes
ou finalement ça n'a pas grand chose à
voir
léger rapport et il faut parler de ce
sujet
la réforme georges klein qui ne
changerait pas le comportement de la
police est au jour le jour
nous avons déjà vu dans ce pays et dans
d'autres pays que même après des
changements dans la loi revient à la
police a continué à agir vite récemment
ne serait-ce que la semaine dernière
monsieur green a été assassiné par un
officier de police parisienne des images
vidéo montrent qu'il s'agit d'un
assassinat et cela a été évoqué dans les
temps un accident tous que cela ne va
pas changer qu'au nouveau téléphone il
faut que les états unis changent en
profondeur
certaines personnes ne mérite pas d'être
officier de police et doivent être
perdant leur travail que par exemple
officielle de benoît avait été soumis à
beaucoup de plaintes dont il n'aurait
pas dû se trouver dans la rue ce jour on
part hier à cette occasion des
patrouilles citoyennes qui face à
l'impuissance de la police prennent le
relais dans les rues de la ville le
maire hansjacob frein les soutiens à ce
que c'est c'est vraiment une solution
selon vous qu'est ce que ça dit croyons
pas les individus nous revenons en fait
un peu en arrière les individus
recommence à
se mêler de la loi mais les différents
individus de la société ont tous leur
propre région disent leur billet face
par exemple à d'autres murs et et ont
bloqué c'est personnes qui vont faire la
politique qualifiée et pourtant il ya
des citoyens qui ont réussi à échapper à
leurs devoirs
par exemple quelqu'un qui pensait et qui
se croyait de voisinage a tué quelqu'un
sans aucune justification donc au moins
ce n'est pas à la bonne celui sur la
question du racisme peut emmener un
déchirement de la société il faudrait
plutôt et se demander quelles réformes
on pourrait mettre en place des
statistiques les statistiques montrent
notamment en fonction de la minorité
afro américaine le policier donc derek
sherwin va fixé sur sa peine le 25 juin
l'amérique retient son souffle on
imagine un verdict éminemment politique
[Musique]
effectivement la grande victoire s'est
jamais qu'il était responsable et
beaucoup de personnes mis à disposition
d'une expertise leur science et je pense
effectivement qu'il sera condamné à une
lourde peine
le système de justice mais je ne pense
pas que cette personne soit vous faites
par nature qui la victime dont on ne
parle pas aujourd'hui
ton papa aujourd'hui c'est sa fille qui
est aujourd'hui à la maison blanche qui
a 12 ans et qui n'a plus de père merci à
la norges rappelle que vous êtes avocat
en direct donc de stamford dans le
connecticut merci d'avoir été avec nous
pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur la proposition de
loi de deux sénateurs sur les
responsabilités pénales
une démarche au suscité par la vive
émotion suite à l' affaire halimi et
puis notre éditorialiste alexis poulin
nous parlera de la présidentielle
à moins d'un an du premier tour les
stratégies se mettent en place et les
parties tentent de s'organiser tant bien
que mal pour certains
[Musique]
il
en avril aura lieu le 60e anniversaire
du vol de youri gagarine en ayant eu la
chance de m'entraîner avec nos collègues
russes j'ai vraiment plongé dans une
atmosphère où j'ai vécu auprès de méroé
gagarine était présent à chaque point de
bâtiments de salles de sport de place de
la cité des étoiles moi je crois
beaucoup dans la diplomatie scientifique
et quand vous parlez de la coopération
scientifique sur la station billard ou
la station spatiale internationale
c'est une forme de diplomatie on a très
peu d'objets aujourd'hui qui peuvent
être des outils diplomatiques aussi aux
six ans il n'y a pas une façon plus
pauvres de défendre un système que de
dire qu'il est moins pire que tout le
peuple
c'était une volonté collective vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sens du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre
il est probable qu'il faille prendre un
certain nombre de mesures un peu
autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu les
libéraux l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est des gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soient pas publics
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
le ghana est frappé par une nouvelle
ruée vers l'or des milliers de
chercheurs dort mal équipées se ruent
vers les mines
obsédé par l'envié de s'enrichir est
drôle alors ces particules john les
enfants sont déchirés entre leurs études
et le travail dans les mines
enfin ma famille était très fort je
pensais faire de mon mieux pour
retourner à l'école parce que quel sera
leur choix
vous êtes renversé par un homme de 92
ans qui perd le contrôle de son véhicule
deux ans et demi plus tard vous vous
imposez comme un espoir français du
tennis fauteuil objectif est les jeux
paralympiques de paris verra comme le
sport m'a toujours sauver le tennis
c'est que c'est mon sport
bon il ya un fauteuil mais je vais
essayer en fait je me suis rendu compte
que c'est ça allait c'était suffisamment
physique pour moi j'ai une vie de
sportif de haut niveau je m'entraîne
tous les jours c'est devenu ma vie la
raison de me lever le matin j'avais
toujours ce vieux rêve de petite fille
de faire du sport de ma vie est
finalement là c'est ce que je réalise
avec les gens de manger un autre combat
non ma vie qui est celui de la sécurité
routière s'agit d'un projet de loi qui
vise à mettre en place des tests
d'aptitude pour tous les conducteurs pas
seulement les seniors on a un contrôle
technique de son véhicule
il faut un contrôle technique de sa
personne et sa l'état doit re doit
imposer loi sur ce sujet là
un féminicide et commis tous les deux à
trois jours en france actuellement
pourquoi il sous ton encore à protéger
totalement les femmes on dit souvent aux
femmes
oser en parler briser le silence nous
savons que seulement 18 19 % des femmes
révèle les violences qu'elles subissent
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya 80% de femmes
qui ne révèle pas les violences qu'elles
subissent aux forces de sécurité dont
celle qui révèle il faut vraiment les
croix et les protéger souvent on met
toute la responsabilité sur la victime
c'est la question de quels sont les
moyens que l'agresseur a mis en oeuvre
qui doit être posée et la loi le dis
très clairement
et souvent on détourne la loi par cette
histoire de consentement on voit bien
qu'on est quand même encore très loin
très loin de ce qui est nécessaire pour
vraiment pouvoir avoir les moyens de
protéger les femmes
là
en avril aura lieu le 60e anniversaire
du vol de youri gagarine en ayant eu la
chance de m'entraîner avec nos collègues
russes
j'ai vraiment plongé dans une atmosphère
où j'ai vécu auprès de méroé gagarine
était présent à chaque point de
bâtiments de salles de sport de place de
la cité des étoiles moi je crois
beaucoup dans la diplomatie scientifique
et quand vous parlez de la coopération
scientifique sur la station mir ou la
station spatiale internationale
c'est une forme de diplomatie on a très
peu d'objets aujourd'hui qui peuvent
être des outils diplomatiques aussi au
cip temps
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour cette deuxième émission tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce mardi 25 mai confiance dans la
justice l'assemblée nationale adopte en
première lecture le projet de loi d'eric
dupond-moretti
pendant que le sénat lui discute de
l'irresponsabilité pénale revenue au
coeur des débats après le jugement de la
cour de cassation dans la sphère sarah
halimi alors l'émotion provoquée par le
jugement justifit-il qu'on modifie la
loi nous en parlerons avec nos invités
dans quelques instants
[Musique]
objectif 2022 à moins d'un an de
l'élection présidentielle en france les
stratégies se mettent en place au duel
en tête souvent annoncée entre eux
emmanuel macron et marine le pen
s'ajoute la question d'un éventuel
troisième homme est selon un dernier
sondage c'est xavier bertrand qui
obtiendrait le meilleur score au premier
tour derrière le duo macron le pen
reviendrons sur cette course qui ne fait
que commencer avec alexis poulain dans
son édito emmanuel macron dénonce un
coup d'état inacceptable et non ce que
l'union européenne va prendre des
sanctions ciblées contre le mali
élection après le coup de force
militaire le président et le premier
ministre de transition été arrêté hier à
bamako
ils ont été conduits au camp de cathy un
haut lieu de l'appareil militaire malien
d'agen s'opposent au nouveau
gouvernement londres demandent leur
libération immédiate
[Musique]
confiance dans la justice l'assemblée
nationale adopte donc en première
lecture le projet de loi d'eric
dupond-moretti pour plus de précisions
nous retrouvons tout de suite en direct
nadège abderrazak en direct du pas d'ego
bonsoir nadège le projet du garde des
sceaux donc adopté en première lecture
absolument et avec 342 voix pour cent 5
contre et 96 abstentions alors c'est un
texte un qui est censé rétablir la
confiance entre les français et
l'institution judiciaire je vous propose
à ce sujet d' écouter la réaction de
deux députés que l'on a pu interroger à
la sortie des débats c'est vraiment une
très petite loi mais alors très très
très petit c'est parce qu'il va
révolutionner la justice dans notre pays
c'est à dire donner davantage de moyens
pour le fonctionnement de notre justice
parce que ces dégâts tout ça le vrai
sujet alors effectivement les avocats
seront davantage protéger ses biens les
procédures seront un peu plus courte de
façon à éviter parfois des abus tout ça
c'est 7 à tête tout ça c'est intéressant
mais enfin franchement c'est pas c'est
pas ça qui va révolutionner l'action de
la justice dans notre pays il ya des
choses qu'on peut pas laisser passer
les amendements déposés par le
gouvernement pendant la manifestation du
19 mai par exemple c'est des choses
n'ont en fait pas une oie sous la
pression d'une manifestation
donc il ya une déception on peut pas
demander à filmer un jugement nous sur
le coup on s'était dit c'est une bonne
idée le peuple fait la loi que des
jugements soient filmés le peuple peu
pour en faire une émission télévisée une
traînée déj ce projet de loi a été
amendée pour répondre à la colère des
forces de l'ordre après les meurtres de
deux policiers absolument stéphanie un
amendement prévoit d'ailleurs de passer
de 22 ans à 30 la peine de sûreté pour
les condamnés à la prison à perpétuité
pour un crime commis contre un policier
ou un gendarme autres dispositions de ce
projet de loi la fin des rappels à la
loi jugée inefficace ou encore la
limitation des réductions de peine pour
les agresseurs des membres des forces de
l'ordre alors pour le grand public l'une
des dispositions phare de ce projet
c'est la possibilité de filmer les
audiences d'un procès d'autres
propositions visent par ailleurs à
améliorer les procédures pénales comme
par exemple la limitation de la durée
des enquêtes préliminaires ou encore le
renforcement de la présomption
d'innocence ou encore du secret de la
défense ce projet de loi devrait être
examiné au sénat ce sera courant
septembre
merci nadège à deraa qu'est justice
toujours elle est passée mais n'a pas
forcément été rendu aux yeux de tous ont
ce qui concerne la sphère sarah halimi
en avril dernier la cour de cassation a
confirmé l'irresponsabilité pénale de
commise et traoré tout en entérinant le
caractère antisémite du crime
une décision qui a suscité émoi mais
aussi incompréhension et dans la foulée
mais les mecs m'ont avait d'ailleurs
indiqué souhaiter au plus vite un
changement de loi le ministre de la
justice présentera donc un projet femmes
et au conseil des ministres
senna lui s'est emparé de ce dossier
propose que l'on certains cas la
question de l'irresponsabilité pénale
soit tranchée à l'issue d'un procès en
partie
et pour les personnes ayant pris des
stupéfiants comme dans la sphère halimi
alors l'émotion provoquée par la cour de
cassation justifie t'elle qu'on modifie
la loi y at il un vide juridique qui
doit statuer sur la responsabilité
pénale du mis en examen si l'abolition
de son discernement a été causée par une
prise de substances volontaire c'est
l'objet de notre décryptage
[Musique]
bonsoir messieurs michel gueïda
psychiatre expert judiciaire merci
d'être avec nous à vos côtés alain penin
expert psychologue bonsoir à vous aussi
première question à la sphère sarah
limite donc soulevé de nombreuses
incompréhensions un changement de loi
est bien une demande sociétale selon
vous alain penin alors sais pas s'il ya
une demande sociétale ce qui est certain
c'est que cette affaire a suscité une
immense émotion a suscité
l'incompréhension a suscité également
des réactions
et effectivement il importe de clarifier
de clarifier les choses de mon point de
vue effectivement vous êtes d'accord
michel qaïda il faut clarifier les
choses et surtout quelles sont les
choses qu'il faut clarifier pour que ce
type de décision n'arrive plus parce que
c'est vrai qu'elle a été très incomprise
et pourtant les juges n'ont fait
qu'appliquer la loi telle qu'elle est
écrite
certes les juges ont appliqué la loi
mais justement la cour de cassation dans
son arrêt du 14 avril a pointé une
certaines failles juridiques qui
existent à savoir le problème posé par
en particulier toxicomanes malades et
les toxicomanes délinquants dans le
monde
c'est là le problème c'est que la loi ne
précise pas très exactement les deux cas
de figure est certes y avait des
habitudes de fonctionnement
c'est à dire que la plupart du temps les
toxicomanes qui n'étaient pas atteints
d'une maladie mentale existantes ou
indépendantes et les alcooliques de la
même façon et c'était plutôt une
circonstance aggravante quand il y avait
des faits délictueux ou criminel et
d'ailleurs les toxicomanes en général
sans qu'ils arrivent un stade criminels
sont considérés comme des délinquants
déjà niveau correctionnel de la
consommation et de la diffusion de la
drogue
donc effectivement a fortiori quand il
était criminel et qu'il n'y avait pas
d'autre pathologie sous jacente et était
considéré comme tout à fait responsable
en général ça se passait comme ça mais
dans l' affaire halimi évidemment qui a
connu un grand un grand intérêt
médiatique émotionnel évidemment là là
on a pointé la lafa etiassé que des
textes ne précise pas exactement ce qui
convient de faire donc comme la cour de
cassation jugeait en matière de droit
suppose aussi la forme juridique est
bien respectée elle a conclu danse dans
un sens ou en faisant un appel du pied
au gouvernement pour qu'il précise à
travers une loi ce qui complique qui
retient l'attention dans cette affaire
c'est que le caractère antisémite a été
retenu nokia une forme de voile à 2
d'actes volontaires
les moqueries en plus que des moqueries
même après cette affaire c'est eh ben
voilà il suffit d'aller prendre des
substances voilà j'en ai même lu fumé un
pétard et elle est tuée qui on veut et
on est exonéré c'est vrai que ça peut
choquer est-ce que c'est comme ça qu'il
faut résumer les choses selon vous c'est
à dire que il ya déjà si vous voulez une
décision au départ du juge d'instruction
qui a conclu dans un sens un haut niveau
de l'instruction elle même cette
décision du juge d'instruction a fait
l'objet d'un recours auprès d'un
tribunal qui la chambre en quelques
sortes très bien que la chambre de
l'instruction qui est une structure qui
est chargée de contrôler les décisions
du juge d'instruction à savoir si du
d'instruction a conclu à l'abolition du
discernement
le sujet doit être généralement donc il
est interné en service psychiatrique
sous la décision du préfet un des
représentants de l'état mais là donc la
décision de du juge d'instruction at t a
été contestée et la chambre de
l'instruction qui donc est une structure
juridique qui existe depuis je crois
2001 enfin qui est qui a rang à cassette
affectation supplémentaires parce
qu'avant ça s'appelait chambre de
l'accusation et je me structure a eu sur
compétences élargies donc structure qui
fonctionne comme un tribunal avec la
présence de l'avocat de la défense
présence de la partie civile et
ministère public avocat général deux
assesseurs un président est donc hissé
et les experts viennent notamment les
experts viennent présenter leur rapport
et
des questions qui leur sont posées et
les avocats interviennent six et la
parole est donnée aux mis-en-cause aussi
en dernier lieu
donc ça fonctionne comme ce qui a choqué
aussi dans cette affaire c'est que au
final il n'y a pas eu de véritable
procès avant de vous faire réagir alain
penin je voudrais vous faire écouter
nathalie goulet sénatrice centriste de
l'orne sur sa proposition de loi
notre volonté n'est pas de juger les
fous comme on l'entend ici ou là nous
souhaitons seulement que dans certaines
circonstances la question de les
responsabilités puissent être tranchée
en toute transparence à l'issue d'un
procès la tenue d'un procès est très
importante pour les familles c'est à
l'issue de ce procès que le tribunal où
la cour se prononcerait sur les
responsabilités du mis-en-cause alain
penin votre avis d'expert judiciaire sur
cette question expert-psychologue les
fous ne doivent pas être punies
satirique s'offir aurait dû ni tour
depuis toujours on ne juge pas les
malades mentaux on ne juge pas les gens
qui agissent sous l' empire une force
laquelle ils n'ont pu résister on ne
juge pas les gens qui commettent des
s'est saoulé c'est d'une pathologie
mentale d'un trouble psychique d'une à
la condition qu'il y ait une
imputabilité c'est-à-dire un lien très
étroit entre la pathologie mentale et le
trouble psychique
par exemple une hallucination par
exemple un délit ou un phénomène
pathologique qui modifie la perception
de la réalité ce qui se passe
effectivement avec la prise de
substances psychoactives c'est que
indéniablement les substances
psychotropes entraîne des véritables
états pathologiques et comme le dit
fort justement michel gueïda il va
falloir faire la différence entre le
troubles pathologiques induit uniquement
par la substance pas et le la
modification comportementale et la
modification psychique du de la
personnalité de l'homme qui est en
difficultés du malade mental qui utilise
en plus des substances psychoactives
donc en effet et c'est ce qui est
important c'est que c'est que l'expert
psychiatre ça ne concerne pas le
psychologue mais l'expert-psychiatre as
à se déterminer pour savoir si au moment
de l'acte
le sujet était dans un état où son
discernement était soit abolie soit
altérée donnez moi il ya quelque chose
qui est quand même choquant pour le
commun des mortels ça veut dire que la
drogue on décide quand même de
l'apprendre et l'a clairement c'est
quelqu'un c'était un jeune homme qui ne
semblait pas spécialement ma lanouf où
dans sa ville tous les jours et ce jour
là il a décidé walad de prendre de la
drogue donc on est un petit peu
responsable de son état tout de même y
avait-il une intention criminelle au
moment de la prise du toxique
c'est la question qu'il faut que nous
nous posions c'est parce qu'en
pensent-ils sheridan
mais évidemment la chose que l'on peut
dire c'est que la prise de toxiques à ce
niveau déjà et fait souvent par des gens
qui sont personnellement en difficulté
ça ne veut pas dire qu'ils soient des
malades mentaux mais l'intention
criminelle la liste tels au moment où le
sujet prend du toxique
c'est ça la véritable question en
revanche c'est vrai que l'effet du
produit est délétère sur la conscience
et sur l'organisation du comportement
lié à cette prise michel goudard sans
cette question justement de volonté ça
enlève finalement toute responsabilité
individuel et le fait de ne pas être
responsable de soi même c'est à dire on
peut un peu ce évidemment dans cette
affaire là comme je n'étais pas à des
experts et la réflexion a été complexe
puisqu'il ya eu je crois trois collèges
d'experts qui n'étaient pas tous du même
avis donc la détermination de l'état
psychiatrique du sujet avant les faits
façon dans la toxicomanie s'étaient
développés dans sa pratique tout cela
mène mériterait une étude approfondie
donc il ya eu une décision de la chambre
de l'instruction qu'il a estimé qu'il
était responsable se dire au même titre
que toutes les personnes atteintes d'une
passion qui traverse donc à parce qu'ils
sont jaloux parce qu'ils sont
orgueilleux et cetera comme que
puissance il traverse une période de
folie en quelque sorte au dernier moment
et il pas question de déresponsabiliser
tous les états passionnel bien
évidemment or là aussi d'habitude
d'une façon générale et sans pouvoir
faire un ferrer exactement sur cette
affaire il était habituel que lors des
expertises effectivement quand il y
avait prise de toxiques ou d'alcool en
dehors de pathologies existantes et de
façon sous jacente dans un contexte où
tout le monde et je suppose et
maintenant connaître les effets très
nocifs sur le fonctionnement psychique
des drogues et de l'alcool
c'est un engager la responsabilité de
par la pratique ça c'était l'habitude
que j'ai toujours connu passage chez 40
ans que chez des expertises et si j'ai
toujours vu sa pratique est presque
toujours comme ça dans le cas présent je
ne peux pas me prononcer et je sais que
dans la commission de quitter commandé
par madame b loubet qui a été finalisé
le 23 avril par le père l'homme le dé la
commune comme unité de monsieur dupont
moretti
les équipes qui étaient missionnés pour
étudier la réforme possible conclut et
qu'il ne fallait pas changer le
fondement des textes mais qu'il
convenait de préciser en particulier le
fonctionnement de la chambre
d'accusation en l'enrichissant et en
précisant son rôle précisé par ailleurs
sur le plan de la symptomatologie et des
maladies mentales
mieux les choses ainsi concernés le
malade toxicomanes et le toxicomane
délinquants et puis veiller aussi à une
amélioration du statut de l'expert c'est
je crois que les experts ne s'en
plaindront pas voilà merci je n'ai pas
coupé
voulez vous laisser venir votre femme
merci en tout cas alors qu'on apprend
précisément que le sénat vient d'adopter
un projet de loi concernant livre
responsabilité pénale que l'on va
découvrir donc ces prochaines heures
merci à vous et toujours en france
toujours en france à moins d'un an de
l'élection présidentielle les stratégies
se mettent en place et les conjectures
vont bon train selon un sondage ifop
fiducial pour lci et le figaro xavier
bertrand le candidat de droite
obtiendrait le meilleur score au premier
tour parmi les candidats potentiels de
son camp derrière marine le pen et
emmanuel macron pour parler de cette
course à la présidentielle qui ne fait
que commencer nous sommes avec alexis
poulain c'est notre rubrique l'édito
[Musique]
bonsoir alexis poulain un an donc du
spot en 2022 la stratégie d' emmanuel
macron de briser en les partis
traditionnels semblent arriver à
maturité mais est ce une assurance pour
lui de gagner même si vous n'êtes pas
madame irma ronces et bien non c'est sûr
les sondages à un an de la
présidentielle c'est toujours un peu
compliqué on se demande où ça peut aller
quels sont les prédictions réel mais
clairement se dessine une stratégie pour
révéler macron très visible après avoir
affaibli les le gauche le parti
socialiste de l'intérieur en étant ni de
droite ni de gauche
et finalement de droite le voilà qui
attaquent vent debout l air le parti
traditionnel et qui essayent de les
scinder en deux entre son centre qu'il
voudrait dépasser 1 au delà de la
république en marche et le rassemblement
national
clairement il veut mettre en scène un
nouveau duel pour 2022 entre lui et
marie le pen
exactement comme en 2010 est le problème
c'est que sa base est assez étriqués
qu'il aura du mal à aller plus loin et
que marine le pen monte dans les
sondages sans rien faire donc c'est un
pari risqué que fait emmanuel macron et
puis on voit bien que dans ces
régionales toute cette stratégie
finalement nationale se met en jeu c'est
le jeu dans les hauts de france avec
eric dupond-moretti agnès
pannier-runacher gérald darmanin ils
sont tous sur une liste contre xavier
bertrand qui pourrait être ce candidat
qui viendraient un peu joué un chien
dans un jeu de quilles et empêcher
emmanuel macron d'être notre candidat de
centre droit social démocrate parce que
on voit que lui monte dans les sondages
c'est un candidat déclaré à droite donc
c'est à un jeu auquel joue entre mâcon
depuis maintenant plus d'un an et on
voit aussi d'ailleurs qu'il essaye de
parler au delà de sa base vers des
publics plus segmentée c'est le cas de
la vidéo sur youtube avec max icarly tôt
pour le veau john mais aussi il est
beaucoup sur tik tok par exemple où il
répond à des segments de deux français
donc on voit qu'il a une approche très
marketing du vote très loin d'un
programme très loin d'un bilan qu'il
pourrait défendre il est là en train de
se vendre comme un produit marketing et
c'est ce qu'il a fait d'ailleurs en 2017
il refait ce coup là en 2022 est ce que
ça peut marcher on le verra tous les
candidats ne sont pas déclarés et comme
je le disais on est à un an de la
présidentielle et a beaucoup moins de
temps maintenant d'airé
ronald qui approche à grand pas qui sont
les siens enjeu national pour l'elysée
qui semble déjà avoir fait une croix sur
la reine ou rappeler qu'en marche c'est
vrai qu'on a l'impression que c'est un
parti déjà mort ou déjà abandonné 1 par
action qui lui avait pourtant donné ses
initiales on sent bien que ce parti est
une étiquette qu'on n'essaye pas de
montrer qu'on essaie plutôt de cacher
donc plutôt un repoussoir mais c'est un
parti utile parce qu'ils les deux partis
de la majorité assis sur un trésor de
guerre en termes d'argent une argent qui
sera bien nécessaire pour la campagne de
2022 mais emmanuel macron va chercher à
dépasser le cadre de la république en
marche avec une plateforme pour un
renouveau présidentielle avec des micro
partis comme celui par exemple d'edouard
philippe qu'il a créé au havre où le
groupe agir ou d'autres issus du modem
ou bien députés démissionnaires de la
république en marche qui vont créer
d'autres groupes pour aller
agrégé une nouvelle majorité
présidentielle d'ailleurs on ne s'y
trompe pas richard ferrand président de
l'assemblée nationale à des jeux de
cette semaine avec edouard philippe le
maire du havre
donc les grandes manoeuvres sont
enclenchées parce qu'il va falloir faire
de la politique politicienne pour
déplacer la république en marche avec
par exemple cette plateforme pour les
causes qui a été mis en ligne mais aussi
agrégé d'autres partis et ne pas
défendre un bilan finalement bien maigre
1 on se demande quelle va être la relaxe
des malades mâcon pour défendre son
bilan gestion calamiteuse du coc vide
l'emploi qui ne va pas tu as l'air la
croissance qui ne va pas très bien avec
les choix qui ont été faits dans cette
gestion de crise mais aussi là où il
devait être grand réformateur des
réformes qui n'arrivent pas à terme
comme celle des retraites l'assurance
chômage critiqué par tous les
partenaires sociaux est il sur le volet
social et bien simplement divisé les
classes de cp en deux c'est assez faible
le pass culture assez faible aussi donc
ça risque d'être compliqué et ces
régionales sont un laboratoire avec
l'idée justement de ne pas présenter de
vraiment de candidats d'un public en
marche comme une chance de gagner ils
ont certes des sièges n'est pas de
vainqueur sans doute donc de les ancrer
quand même dans les régions parce que
aux municipales ça n'a pas fonctionné
avec typiquement en paca ce qu'il s'est
passé avec renaud muselier de faire un
peu le coup
au sein de listes existantes que ce soit
l air ou ou d'autres partis qui
accepteront d'avoir des députés de la
république en marche à leurs côtés et ça
c'est très ancien monde 1 typiquement le
de parachutage daniel spagnou d'acheter
dans notre france qui a posé question
puisque dans son cabinet travaille son
concubin elle s'en est expliqué au micro
d'une radio nationale en disant que tout
était en règle mais ça pose quand même
beaucoup de questions sur la façon dont
sont gérés encore une fois ces
candidatures et on en parle peut-être un
peu moins alexis poulin et la gauche
dans tout ça oui c'est vrai qu'on en
parle de la gauche mais uniquement pour
ses affaires ap intrafamiliales j'ai
envie de dire où on voit que l'union de
la gauche est en train de s'amenuiser de
partir loin vers l'horizon
on attaque côté jean luc mélenchon 1 qui
choisi de tracer sa route en regardant
de loin c'est hypothétique nom de la
gauche qui ressemble fort à un accord de
partie entre eux élevé le ps le pc est
sans doute pour les législatives et au
delà
et on voit bien que même si élevé on se
pose beaucoup de questions non avec un
yannick jadot qui aimeraient enjamber la
primaire du parti pour être le candidat
désigné d'office faire un accord
immédiat avec anne hidalgo hidalgo elle
aussi bien gênés 1 par la candidature
d'audrey pulvar en région parisienne
elle est obligée de la soutenir bien sûr
c'est la candidat ps mais elle a pris
ses distances
elle est empêtrée dans la gestion de la
ville de paris donc on voit bien que la
gauche est totalement à contre courant
finalement des préoccupations des
français uniquement occupés préoccupé
par ces affaires d'union ses affaires
familiales sa survie tout simplement
parce que c'est ce qui se joue un pour
le parti socialiste en l'occurrence
olivier faure qui a dit tout et son
contraire la semaine dernière qui a bien
du mal à expliquer la ligne du parti
socialiste donc vraiment à gauche on ne
les voit pas en ordre de bataille
sauf pour jean luc mélenchon qui a
choisi lui de se lancer très tôt en
campagne avec une plate forme
programmatique et déjà beaucoup de
meetings prévus mais on est loin encore
du conte et de l'union de la gauche
donc on voit bien que en ce moment c'est
vraiment une drôle de campagne qui
s'annonce beaucoup de communication
beaucoup de marketing sans doute un peu
de
pas grande aussi et on est loin encore
de cette élection présidentielle il y
aura sans doute beaucoup de choses à
dire d'ici là et on est déjà avec vous
notamment mercier alexis poulain rester
avec nous dans quelques instants nous
serons avec le journalisme et 8 ans tout
juste relaxé pour s'être introduit sur
le tarmac de l'aéroport d'annecy lors
d'une manifestation écologiste il
répondre à nos questions et puis
direction le mali emmanuel macron
dénonce un coup d'état inacceptable
annonce que l'union européenne va
prendre des sanctions ciblées contre le
pays
[Musique]
le terme banlieue voir le terme cité
c'est forcément péjoratif c'est vrai que
les médias ont un regard on va dire
assez particulier des banlieues et qui
dérange aujourd'hui et en donne
séparation que la banlieue ça se
résoudrait cas des jeunes violents
contre une police qui serait son travail
c'est plus compliqué que ça on est
français on est fiers de vivre dans ces
quartiers même si à des difficultés et
la moindre des choses c'est d'inscrire
aussi notre empreinte canton quand on
participe à la vie de la société et
malheureusement n'y a pas cette
reconnaissance
aujourd'hui je pense que le changement
viendra d'abord à travers cette
conscientisation des citoyens des
quartiers populaires on parle également
des deux zones de reconquête
républicaine
au final derrière ces mots qu'est ce qui
casse qui se cachent des politiques font
pour les gens mais sans les gens c'est à
dire qui donne cette impression de faire
de vouloir changer les choses mais
concrètement politiquement ils ne le
font pas
en féminines ici des commis tous les
deux à trois jours en france
actuellement
pourquoi il joue ton encore à protéger
totalement les femmes on dit souvent
femmes osé en parler
briser le silence nous savons que
seulement 18 19 % des femmes révèle les
violences qu'elles subissent donc ça
veut dire qu'il ya 80% de femmes qui ne
révèle pas les violences qu'elles
subissent aux forces de sécurité dont
celle qui rêvait il faut vraiment les
croix et les protéger souvent on met
toute la responsabilité sur la victime
c'est la question de quels sont les
moyens que l'agresseur a mis en oeuvre
qui doit être posée et la loi le dis
très clairement
et souvent on détourne la loi par cette
histoire de consentement on voit bien
qu'on est quand même encore très loin
très loin de ce qui est nécessaire pour
vraiment pouvoir avoir les moyens de
protéger les femmes
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
le ms a exhorté certains pays d'afrique
à ne pas détruire les vaccins anti
qu'ovide péri mais il faut craindre une
vaccination low cost en afrique lors une
vaccination à l'est une vaccination
savez la vaccination ce n'est pas elle
n'a pas commencé avec les auditeurs
le problème ça reste quand même
l'approvisionnement est ce que c'est la
faute des pays les plus riches qui
accapare justement les productions de
l'accent où est le mécanisme de la
vaccination vous savez ça a soulevé
beaucoup danger sur la question de la
solidarité si on peut en faire plus en
terme de solidarité de partage
c'est vers cela c'est quelque chose
d'absolument important on sait que le
nigeria affirme qu'il élabore son propre
vaccin contre le coc vie de 19 pour en
finir avec justement la dépendance
vis-à-vis des laboratoires étrangers que
ça soit le sénégal le nigeria l'afrique
du sud
beaucoup de pays ont cette ambition
l'avoir amené l'agenda de la santé
publique au top des priorités c'est
quelque chose que nous saluons
énormément au niveau de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
et puis
[Musique]
21h30 soyez les bienvenus si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rt france le
journaliste matthieu hutin a été relaxé
ce matin il connaîtra le contenu du
délibéré dans les dix prochains jours
les membres d'extinction et médian ont
pour leur part écopé de 200 euros
damende mais tu es hutin s'était
introduit sur le tarmac de l'aéroport
delphi pour couvrir une manifestation de
militants écologistes venus mener une
action coup de poing pour protester
contre le renouvellement du bail de
l'aéroport c'était le 12 septembre
dernier
pour en parler nous le retrouvons
précisément de mathieu hutin rédacteur
en chef dave 2 aux radios bonsoir mais
tu t'en merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france la relaxe 1 au titre de la
liberté d'information justice a été
rendue on imagine un soulagement
bonsoir stéphanie de rue oui un
soulagement évidemment et on ne peut pas
parler ce soir de liberté de la presse
au de liberté d'expression sans avoir
une pensée évidemment pour romane alors
protesté beach qui a été qui a été
enlevée qui a été kidnappé la communauté
internationale condamne évidemment mais
je crois que ce n'est pas parce qu'il
passait assez fort on va revenir sur le
sujet mais on ne peut pas parler de
liberté de la presse ce soir si on n'a
pas une pensée pour romane protesté
beach oui je suis soulagée même si
effectivement on s'attendait à cette
décision puisque mon confrère gérard
fumex avait été relaxée il ya de ça un
mois puisque les auditions les
convocations était en décalé toutefois
effectivement ce qu'on peut regretter
dans cette affaire c'est que on est dû
aller s'expliquer à la barre du tribunal
et qu'on a entendu des choses pas très
sympa à voir même mensongères et que
même un moment mais reprocher on est
remis en cause mais ma qualité de
journaliste en nous disant en me disant
simplement monsieur juste à contrarier
pas de carte de presse donc vous n'êtes
pas journaliste
la radio qui vous emploie est
associative donc n'importe quelle
association embauche un étudiant et puis
il devient journaliste non
je crois qu'il faut être sérieux deux
minutes j'ai un contrat de travail de
journaliste pour une radio qui est
conventionnée avec le conseil supérieur
de l'audiovisuel il faut arrêter de dire
n'importe quoi est resté est resté
sérieux dans cette période qui est
compliquée où on a des manifestations
qui sont interdites c'est encore le cas
ce week end à annecy alors finalement
elle a été autorisée par le tribunal de
grenoble
la manifestation de pour la liberté de
manifestation des 100 masques 1 comme on
l'appelle ici
mais voilà labellisation soutien au
peuple palestinien a été interdite à
paris on a aujourd'hui dans notre pays
des éléments qui sont inquiétants quant
à la liberté d'expression la liberté de
la presse
constamment vos poursuite quelques mois
encore vous avec le recul est ce que
vous voulez expliqué elle était légitime
selon vous gênez serment parlant jusqu'à
un certain point on l'avait déjà évoqué
sur votre antenne il était pour moi
normal de devoir s'expliquer à la
gendarmerie
parce qu'effectivement n'était sur le
taxiway de l'aéroport au dancing non pas
sur les pistes comme l'a prétendu le
ministère public
par contre de devoir aller jusqu à la
barre du tribunal pour le répéter c'est
choquant est que le ministère public
essaye de passer en force avec des
arguments de sécurité en prétextant que
la sécurité civile ne pouvait pas
travailler en prétextant que le trafic
aérien était perturbé ça par contre
c'est choquant on a dépassé les limites
moi je suis je suis pour le débat public
donc qu'on s'interroge pourquoi y avait
des journalistes avec treize militants
sur le tarmac de l'aéroport d'annecy le
12 septembre 2020 ok mais au poste de
gendarmerie ça suffit pas besoin d'aller
à la barre du tribunal avec d'être mis
comme ça d'être jetés comme ça en pâture
devant devant la justice vous parliez de
liberté de la presse 1 la france n'est
plus que 34e au classement mondial 2021
de la liberté de la presse établi par
reporters sans frontières diriez vous
que les conditions dans lesquelles vous
travaillez
ont changé au fil des années bien que
vous ne soyez pas très âgées
effectivement merci stéphanie de muri
c'est très gentil
elles ont changé mais ils ont changé
dans un délai qui est très récent ce
qu'on peut observer c'est que depuis la
le mouvement des dix gilet jaune
on a d'une part une défiance des
journalistes de la part de certaines
personnes et d'autre part des forces de
l'ordre qui sont beaucoup plus tendu
avant ça tout se passait très très bien
et surtout j'ai envie de dire surtout en
province comme c'est le cas ici
après elles se sont tendues depuis les
gilet jaune sont tendus également avec
basse et son petit masque les gens qui
sont sceptiques mais pourquoi elles
s'étendent
elle se tourne parce que on essaye de
moins en moins de donner la parole aux
gens en interdit des manifestations
là on va réprimer sévèrement puisque ce
matin des militants étaient condamnés et
alors le parquet se prend les pieds dans
le tapis
dans cette histoire aussi le premier
militant a été condamné à 200 euros
d'amendé avec sursis
les six suivants ont reçu une
réquisition pour 200 euros damende ferme
mais ont reçu l'appel avant d'avoir la
condamnation
et puis ce matin trois nouveaux ont
comparu et e.on ont été condamnés à 3
100 à 200 euros d'amendé ferme
donc on ne sait plus sait plus où donner
de la tête on ne comprend pas le
comportement de la justice vis-à-vis des
militants d'extinction rébellion et des
amis de la terre
c'est ça qui stresse les gens les gens
ne peuvent plus s'exprimer sans être
pointés du doigt
en fait le débat public souffre d'un
syndrome qui vient à mon sens des
réseaux sociaux c'est à dire qu' on ne
peut pas avoir de débat public il n'y a
pas de mise à mort à la fin il faut
forcément qui en inquiète or et qu'on
n'entende plus à la fin non on peut
opposer deux points de vue et et les
opposer avec avec richesse avec
franchise sans que ça se termine par des
arrestations ou un lâchage sur les
réseaux sociaux de dunes ou de l'autre
partie dernière question le projet de
loi sécurité globale avec son fameux
article 24 1 finalement censuré il a
fait couler beaucoup d'encre à cet
article par le conseil constitutionnel
censure est en tout cas ce n'est que
justice
selon vous ce n'est que justice
non moi je regrette qu'il faille aller
jusqu'au dernier rempart de cette
démocratie
cette république pour pour qu'on censure
vraiment ce qu'il ya censuré parce qu'il
reste quand même des choses dans le
texte qui sont qu'ils sont inquiétants
que l'article 24 l'ancien article 24
parce qu'il a pu tenir là c'est pas tout
le texte
effectivement c'est une dérive il a été
censuré ouf parce que c'était vraiment
la chose la plus inquiétante dans dans
ce texte mais il reste d'autres choses
et je crois que nous parlementaires aura
dit s'inquiéter bien avant et faire le
boulot
bien avant ça c'est très inquiétant et
puis on ne parle plus du tout du rapport
de jean marie delarue des journalistes
des forces de l'ordre ont travaillé
pendant des semaines à beauvau pour elle
à bord et une liste de propositions qui
était très intéressante et ce travail
pour le moment n'est utilisé par
personne et ça également c'est un
élément qui est regrettable donc oui en
ce moment on va jusqu'au au bout des
parachutes que la démocratie française
peut utiliser pour éviter de tomber
réellement dans dans la dérive mais on y
est tombé en quelque part ce week end
on est dans un pays où le ministre de
l'intérieur a porté plainte contre une
opposante politique qui avait porté un
jugement de valeur sur une manifestation
des forces de l'ordre mais sans porter
injures ont plus est une ancienne
journaliste dont elle connaît très bien
les règles est malgré tout le se
retrouva qu avec une plante donc un
quelques elle va l'être le parachute
cette fois ci pour rappeler le ministre
de l'intérieur à la raison moi je me
pose la question j'attends de voir ce
qui va se passer
merci beaucoup m et 1 2h de goût d'avoir
été rappelé en direct sur arte france
dans le reste de l'actualité les femmes
de chambre de l'hôtel ibis mais tignol à
paris ont eu gain de cause après deux
mois de grève le groupe hôtelier
français a fini par céder à leurs
revendications après des mois de
négociations avec les syndicats des
avocats le point avec banshee scènes de
liesse à la sortie de l'hôtel ibis des
batignolles mais pour cause c'est la fin
d'une lutte de près de deux ans pour ces
femmes de chambre qui viennent tout
juste de signer un accord avec
l'hôtelier
après huit mois de grève et 14
d'activité partielle de cette façon mais
dieu merci on a gagné on a du temps car
on n'avait pas à l'aser victoires et les
victoires ça fait bien on a bâti on a
gagné on est très content en juillet
2010 9 34 femmes de chambre sur 40 que
compte l'hôtel avait entamé une grève
puis saisi les prud'hommes employé par
la société stn sous traitants du
nettoyage
elle dénonce l inégalité de traitement
entre elles et les salariés de l'hôtel
ibis notamment en termes de rémunération
et de conditions de travail une grande
victoire
une très belle victoire et c'est une
histoire pour nous qui va rester à vide
en voilà dans notre vie ses mots quand
même au les femmes là c'est qu'ils ont
ce métier et on a on ne mérite pas ça on
ne mérite pas de telma traitance dans
leur établissement et il faut que aussi
les autres collègues aussi n'ai pas peur
il faut qu'à prendre courage de suivre
notre exemple sorti et d'annoncés
passées à beaucoup a dénoncé dans les
hôtels l'accord signé par la cgt hpe la
foncière immobilière d'accord accord une
veste ou encore estée en groupe prévoit
en plus une augmentation de salaire de
250 à 500 euros brut par mois
la baisse du nombre indicative de
chambre a nettoyé par heure un combat
sans relâche porté par la cgt hpe dont
les représentants étaient émus aux
larmes à la sortie de la rencontre
une avancée significative pour claude
davy animateurs syndical cgt hpe qui
voit là une victoire historique
ce n'est pas gagné d'avancé puisque dès
le début de cette grève on a dit aux
salariés attention on s'attaque au big
up au groupe accor qui est très très
difficile dans la dans la négociation
quand on a des conflits du travail donc
par tpr et prévoyez de partir pour une
grève longue et dure on a été cash dès
le début et les filles l'ont bien
compris et effectivement on arrive après
22 mois de lutte à un succès avec cette
victoire incroyable que pour ma part
j'ai jamais vu dans ma carrière
syndicale
l'ibis de clichy-batignolles deuxième
plus grand hôtel ibis de france avec
plus de 700 chambres est devenu par ce
combat le plus important
j'avais mené par la cgt hpe le symbole
des conditions de travail dégradées des
femmes de chambre avec cette victoire
ces femmes souhaitent donner leur vie à
toutes les femmes de chambre de se
battre pour plus de reconnaissance et de
justice sociale
la france condamne le coup de force de
l'homme fort du pouvoir malien le
colonel simi gorrite à l exige la
libération du président et du premier
ministre de transition était hier à
bamako
ils ont été conduits au camp de cathy au
lieu de l'appareil militaire malien leur
arrestation a eu lieu quelques heures
après avoir formé un nouveau
gouvernement à la suite de la démission
du président du précédent confronté à
une contestation grandissante grâce
zahia pour les explications une annonce
gouvernementale qui met le feu aux
poudres hier par la voix du secrétaire
général de la présidence malienne le
nouveau gouvernement a été annoncée sont
nommés membres du gouvernement en
qualité de miss black défense et des
anciens combattants général de brigade
souleymane double quelques heures après
les rumeurs ont été confirmées
le président de la transition banda au
et son premier ministre moctar ouane ont
été conduits dans le camp militaire de
kati fief de la junte
c'est également là que l'ex président
ibrahim boubacar keïta avait été emmenée
lors du putsch du 18 août 2020 les
réactions internationales ne se sont pas
fait attendre
le condamnons
ce qui s'est passé au mali les dernières
heures le kidnapping du président et du
premier ministre et nous soutenons la
communication qui a été adressé par la
cédéao et par l'union africaine
le comité local de suivi de la
transition exige la libération immédiate
et inconditionnelle de ces autorités et
souligne que les éléments militaires qui
les détiennent seront tenus
personnellement responsables de leur
sécurité profondément préoccupé par la
détention des dirigeants civils de la
transition malienne j'appelle au calme
et à leur libération inconditionnelle
mon représentant spécial travail avec la
cedeao l'union africaine et les acteurs
internationaux soutenant la transition
politique en cours
suite au coup d'état sous la pression
internationale les militaires s'était
pourtant engagé à rendre le pouvoir à
des civils
élu à l'issue de 18 mois de transition
et non trois ans comme il l'estimé
nécessaire mais il ya dix jours face à
une contestation politique et sociale
grandissante le premier ministre moctar
ouane a présenté la démission de son
gouvernement avec pour mission de former
une nouvelle équipe
le grand point d'interrogation était
alors la place qui serait faite aux
militaires l'éviction de deux éléments
influents issus de la junte
sadio camara et modibo koné
respectivement ministres de la défense
et de la sécurité pourraient avoir été
la cause de ce coup de force militaire
des événements qui interviennent dans un
climat social et politique tendu
l'union nationale des travailleurs du
mali a annoncé hier la reconduction
d'une grève de cinq jours pour souligner
l'échec des négociations avec les
autorités de transition
si l'objectif de ce remaniement était de
présenter un gouvernement plus
représentatif des acteurs de la société
civile et de la classe politique
la jambe qui ne s'est pour le moment pas
exprimés ne semble pas encore prête à
céder sa place et pour en parler nous
sommes avec babar mais d'un journaliste
bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france emmanuel macron qui donc dénonce
un coup d'état inacceptable annonce que
l'union européenne allait prendre des
sanctions ciblées contre le mali est ce
que vous vous attendiez à une réaction
de la france il ya une telle réaction de
fermeté de la part du chef de l'état ah
oui oui mais je voudrais juste quand
même à rectifier dans l'élément de cet
après midi qu'elle est suspendue depuis
le contexte du pays
donc ça tu es jeux pour les éléments
mais bon la situation au mali
[Musique]
on s'attendait à ça de notamment depuis
ce communiqué dé la transition qui dit
qui dit qu'il a mis au kiel a mis le
président est le meilleur ministre dés
leurs prérogatives dont ce qui fait en
fait des fêtes s'agit tout simplement
qu'ils savent qu'ils sont écartés ne
souhaitait la transition au mali etc qui
fait automatiquement
et effectivement qu'il fallait
s'attendre à la réaction de la
communauté internationale
je veux juste rappeler que la communauté
internationale était attaquée mais quand
même été très compréhensifs si on peut
le dire comme ça avec avec le coup
d'état du 18 derniers et donc il n'y a
pas eu de sens de changer d mali
pratiquement est il de la pression
7 vous dit
là était compréhensive comment vous vous
expliquer cette entre guillemets
indulgence de la part de la communauté
internationale
en 2020 le 18 août quand même c'était
suite à peu près quatre mois de
contestation à les rues du praticable
des barricades
par contre contre l'ancien gouvernement
ou à l'ancien pouvoir des riverains
boubacar keita
donc c'était presque une sorte de sortie
trimestre de sortie de crise n'est ce
pas qui paralysait le pays depuis depuis
tout depuis quatre mois et donc et les
matins la casse ont été compliquées déjà
au niveau des eaux au nouveau au niveau
du nord mais mais aussi les centres avec
avec avec avec le la présence du groupe
et dia 10 mais aussi qu'on vous savez il
ya il ya plus de 11000 à casques bleus
qui sont présents au mali pour la
stabilité du pays et ils ont quelques
milliers de soldats de l'armée a
clairement rappelé que c'est bien elle
qui tenait les rênes
est ce que on peut qualifier ça de
nouveau coup d'état selon vous ce sont
les termes que vous en paierez emploi
riez riez
techniquement oui techniquement quand
vous avez les seulement des termes
juridiques
si vous vous rappelez ces derniers temps
quand les armées maliennes même des
opérations de lutte contre le terrorisme
et à chaque fois qu'il ya des réseaux
m'a dit qu'ici on dit pied ils sont ce
qu'ils sont et alizé danse et des mois
juridique en fait et donc le fait de
prononcer les communiqués qui étaient
mis hors délai au délire
au délà pour le locatif c'est tout
simplement unique
c'est un coup d'état dernière question
quelle marge de manoeuvre
finalement pour le pouvoir de transition
au mali non ça va être très compliqué
parce que n'oubliez pas que la hantise
des officiers c'est ce pour éviter un
affrontement militaire comme ce qui
s'est passé en 2000 tous les sports
d'hiver
donc ça c'est vraiment c'est la priorité
des priorités des militaires surtout pas
d'affrontement militaire malien ça c'est
la pureté des émois avoir un risque
quand même parce qu'il ya une mission de
la cédéao qui viennent tenue cet après
midi à bamako qui a voulu rencontrer les
led
les colonels mais malheureusement ils
n'ont pas pu ils ont remboursé et chemin
parce qu'il est selon ce que j'ai j'ai
entendu à des manifestations
c'est la route donc ça a été très
compliqué probablement on va aller vers
un côté la cedh yahoo
et si les choses se compliquent hommes
il ya des possibilités choses
s'aggravent et 5 sont ciblés mais comme
je n'ai encore haut débit des quelque
chose et j'espère merci d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur arte france pour nous
évoquer cette situation au mali et on
part à présent on centrafrique aux
abords de la ville stratégique de boire
une route ronnie le cameroun à bangui
elle permet de ravitailler en
marchandises la capacité centrafricaine
et le reste du pays
un axe routier vital pour l'économie
parfois pris pour cible par les rebelles
reportage
reportage sur place d'antoine claireaux
nous nous trouvons sur une base aérienne
principalement utilisés par des
appareils des nations unies et d'ici
quelques minutes
nous allons nous envoler vers une
localité stratégique tenu par les forces
armées centrafricaines c'est parti en
effet la ville de boire et stratégique
dans le sens où elle se trouve sur un
axe routier vital pour l'économie
centrafricaine
cette route relie le cameroun à bangui
et c'est un axe extrêmement important
pour l'économie et le commerce du pays
car c'est lui qui vient à ravitailler
bangui et le reste du pays
en marchandises et certaines certains
camions sont parfois pris pour cible par
les rebelles comme ici il y a tout juste
quelques jours quand dr tu es tout seul
qui attendent par un cadre on est
attaqué en effet pour parer aux attaques
tous les jours sont organisés des grands
convois rassemblant des dizaines de
camions qui se refilent donc sous
escorte jusqu'à la capitale depuis la
frontière avec le cameroun pour la
banlieue où on appelle ça mc morrow et
ça a été bloqué donc la ville de banias
a été asphyxié mais avec nos frères
russes nous tous les jours nous avons un
des camions à bangui le convoi se passe
d'une manière très correcte bord de plus
de 50 véhicules et c'est en cadets le au
début et à la faire ou même mieux on va
trouver des éléments etc ça n'a
carrément mixte avec les choix
graphiques et les chansons et le convoi
s'est plus développement malgré tout des
mouvements de bandes armées sont
régulièrement observés avec parfois des
accrochages ces bandits font
éruption à des moment venu à n'importe
quelle heure sur les axes donc ça
constitue vraiment un danger
j'ai remercié avec la présence de nos
forces
déficit que la fac à la gendarmerie la
police n'ose aller les russes et autres
on fait que bon il ya quand même le
chemin que vous pouvez voir juste
derrière moi et régulièrement empruntée
par les rebelles et c'est pour cette
raison que les forces centrafricaines
appuyés par leurs alliés russes se sont
installés ici un avant poste pour
contrôler les mouvements de troupes dans
le secteur on est là par rapport à ce
tag cela c'est ce tact irak et les
malfrats utilisent beaucoup et ce même
sur le passé ils ont venu tirer sur
l'auto base ils ont tiré des parcs
dérogatoire autres bases et on a riposté
ils ont peu fuite on l'aura compris cet
axe de communication est vital pour
l'économie du pays
c'est véritablement un combat quotidien
pour les forces centrafricaines épaulé
par les instructeurs russes que de
rendre cette route plus sûre et c'est la
fin de cette émission prochain point
complet sur l'actualité dans quelques
minutes
[Musique]
le ms a exhorté certains pays d'afrique
à ne pas détruire les vaccins anti covit
péri mais il faut craindre une
vaccination low cost en afrique lors une
vaccination reste une vaccination savez
la vaccination ce n'est pas elle n'a pas
commencé avec la guitare
le problème ça reste quand même
l'approvisionnement est ce que c'est la
faute des pays les plus riches qui
accapare justement les productions de l
accent ou et le mécanisme de la
vaccination vous savez ça a soulevé
beaucoup d'enjeux sur la question de la
solidarité si on peut en faire plus en
terme de solidarité de partage de ces
bacs cela c'est quelque chose
d'absolument important on sait que le
nigeria affirme qu'il élabore son propre
vaccin contre le coc vie de 19 pour en
finir avec justement la dépendance
vis-à-vis des laboratoires étrangers
que ce soit le sénégal le nigeria
l'afrique du sud beaucoup de pays ont
cette admission l'avoir amené l'agenda
de la santé publique au top des
priorités c'est quelque chose que nous
saluons énormément au niveau de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé